Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. In marked contrast to her childhood treatment in Scotland, where she was considered at first a sickly child unlikely to live, and later a pawn in a dynastic game, even at five years old Mary was hailed as a figure of romance in France, a brave little queen who had been forced to flee the barbaric Scots, the cruel English for the safe arms of all-embracing France. The stage was already set in French minds for the appearance of a childish heroine. To their satisfaction, Mary Stuart, with her charm, her prettiness, and the natural docility of youth, was ideal material to be moulded into the playing of this golden roll.
感谢收听《历史的 Rest》节目。若想每周收听独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这与她在苏格兰的童年遭遇形成了鲜明对比——在苏格兰，她起初被视为一个命不久矣的病弱儿童，后来又被当作王朝博弈中的一枚棋子；然而即便在五岁时，玛丽在法国就被奉为浪漫主义的化身：一个被迫逃离野蛮苏格兰人和残酷英国人、投向张开双臂拥抱她的法国怀抱的勇敢小女王。法国人的心中早已为这位童年女英雄的登场铺好了舞台。正如他们所愿，玛丽·斯图尔特凭借她的魅力、美貌以及年轻人天生的温顺，成为了被塑造为这一黄金角色理想的材料。
So that was Lady Antonia Fraser in her celebrated biography of Mary, Queen of Scots. the impact that the infant, well not really infant because she's five years old, but the young Scottish Queen makes on the French court after she arrives in France in the summer of 1548. And in our first episode, you set the scene, didn't you, by talking about the sort of turbulent politics of Mary's childhood, the death of her father and so on when she was only a week old, then all this complicated political game with Henry VIII and with the French court. So just remind us what went on there. Yeah, so the rough wooing. Henry VIII wanted Mary Queen of Scots to marry his son, the
以上是安东尼娅·弗雷泽夫人（Lady Antonia Fraser）在其关于苏格兰女王玛丽的著名传记中所述的内容。这描述了这位婴儿——其实算不上婴儿，因为她已经五岁了——这位年轻的苏格兰女王在1548年夏天抵达法国后，对法国宫廷产生的影响。而在我们的第一集里，你为我们梳理了背景，对吧？你谈到了玛丽童年时期动荡的政治局势，比如她父亲去世时她才一周大，接着是与亨利八世以及法国宫廷之间所有这些复杂的政治博弈。那么，请给我们提醒一下，当时到底发生了什么？是的，也就是所谓的“粗暴求婚”（Rough Wooing）。亨利八世想让苏格兰女王玛丽嫁给他的儿子——
future Edward VI. He thought he'd got the deal, then it got ripped up. He got absolutely irate and sent the English to burn and slaughter and loot, which they then did for eight years. And the impact of this ultimately is that Mary, Queen of Scots, French mother, Mary of Guise, who is part of France's leading noble dynasty, she's able to foil the English and secure a French match for her daughter. And when I say a French match, I mean, it's the most brilliant French match imaginable. Because when Mary Stuart, after a perilous and storm-wracked voyage from Scotland, and you were very sniffy about her failure
未来的爱德华六世。他以为这笔交易已经稳了，结果却被撕毁了。他勃然大怒，派遣英国军队进行烧杀抢掠，而他们随后的确这样做了八年。这一切最终造成的影响是，苏格兰女王玛丽的法国母亲吉斯的玛丽（属于法国领先的贵族王朝）成功挫败了英国人，并为她的女儿谋得了一门法国婚事。而当我提到法国婚事时，我的意思是，这是一门能够想象到的最辉煌的法国婚事。因为当玛丽·斯图尔特在经历了从苏格兰出发充满危险和暴风雨的航程之后——当时你对她没有晕船一事表现得非常不屑，但我认为这是历史的证据。
to succumb to seasickness, but I think it's historical proof. I wouldn't say sniffy, I'd say bracingly skeptical. Go on, continue. Young Mary, Queen of Scott steps onto French soil and she does so as a future Queen of France because her betrothed is the Dauphin himself. And this is the eldest son of Henri II, Henry II, François, or we'll call him Francis because we're being very Anglophone in our treatment of French names. I read in your notes, Tom, you've written, I think this is massive punching down from
我不会说是不屑，我会说是振奋的怀疑。接着说，继续。年轻的苏格兰女王玛丽踏上了法国的土地，她是以法国未来王后的身份抵达的，因为她的未婚夫正是王太子本人。他是亨利二世（Henri II）的长子，弗朗索瓦（François），或者我们按英语习惯把法国名字读作弗朗西斯（Francis）。我在你的笔记里读到，汤姆，你写道——我觉得这是你在向下降维打击——你写道：“他并不是他本可以成为的那种帅哥。”紧接着下一句是：“比玛丽小一岁，所以他四岁。”
you, you've written, he wasn't the hunk he might have been. And then the next line, one year younger than Mary, so he's four. Yeah. So I think that's a bit harsh. And you mock him as being short. I mean, all four year olds are short. I think it's fair to say. Well, he's abnormally short, but Mary is abnormally tall. So there's a disproportion in height. He's got a stutter. and you laugh at him about that. What do you mean I laugh at him?
是的。所以我觉得这有点苛刻。而且你还嘲笑他个子矮。我的意思是，所有四岁小孩个子都很矮，我觉得这样说很公平。嗯，他是异常地矮，但玛丽异常地高。所以身高比例很不协调。他有口吃，你还因此嘲笑他。我怎么嘲笑他了？
I'm not laughing at him. I'm just setting the historical record straight. And you also mock him very cruel remarks in the notes about his two left feet. Yeah. He can't dance. Mary loves dancing. He can't dance. Mary's already a brilliant dancer.
我没有嘲笑他。我只是在澄清历史记录。而且你在笔记里对他的“两只左脚”还进行了非常残酷的嘲笑。对。他不会跳舞。玛丽喜欢跳舞，他不会跳舞。玛丽已经是一位出色的舞者了。
Brilliant dancer. She's five and she's a brilliant dancer and she can steer the ship single-handedly through a storm. Unbelievable. She's very, very precocious. But, but actually Francis is great. He's weedy, but he's plucky. Come on, he's four.
出色的舞者。她才五岁，就是个出色的舞者，而且她还能在风暴中单枪匹马掌舵。难以置信。她非常非常早熟。但是，但是其实弗朗西斯很棒。他虽然瘦弱，但很有骨气。拜托，他才四岁。
Actually the two of them get on tremendously well. Yeah. He's, he's not just plucky, but, but actually very smart. And Mary already has a kind of instinctive sense of what is expected of her, how to play to the gallery. And so she and Francis, everyone agrees they make an adorable couple. A charming couple. Charming couple.
事实上，他们两个相处得极其融洽。对。他不仅有骨气，而且实际上非常聪明。玛丽已经有一种本能的感觉，知道别人对她有什么期望，以及如何讨好大众。因此，无论是她还是弗朗西斯，所有人都一致认为他们是一对可爱的情侣。一对迷人的情侣。迷人的情侣。
Age five and four. No, Tom, don't defend it. You love it. Listen, on these seconds, the King of France, he's like you, he's drunk the iron brew and he's massively, he thinks Mary, Queen of Scots is brilliant, doesn't he? The most perfect child I've ever seen, he says. This is historical testimony, Dominic, which you're sneering at and which I'm just laying it out as it is. It is what it is. And actually he's so impressed by Mary that he gives orders that she should have precedence over his own daughters in royal processions. And this isn't just because she's the betrothed to the Dauphin, but because she's already
一个五岁，一个四岁。不，汤姆，别为这辩护了。你很喜欢。听着，在这几秒钟里，法国国王——他就像你一样，喝了铁饮（Iron Brew）——他极度……他认为苏格兰女王玛丽太棒了，对吧？他说：“这是我见过最完美的孩子。”这是历史证词，多米尼克，而你却在冷嘲热讽，我只是在如实摆出事实。事实就是如此。事实上，他对玛丽印象如此深刻，以至于下令在皇家游行中，她的排位要在他的亲生女儿们之前。这不仅因为她是王太子的未婚妻，还因为她本身就
a queen in her own right. And clearly, you know, she's poised, charming and regal all in one. She's a complete package. And also he says that she should get nicer clothes than his own daughters. She turn up in Scottish fashions. Well we'll come to the issue of Scottish fashions in due course. I mean, I get the sense that you already hate her because of this.
是一位拥有独立主权的女王。很显然，你看，她既沉着冷静、迷人又具王者风范，集所有优点于一身。她是个完美的人选。而且他还说，她应该穿比他亲女儿们更好的衣服。她穿着苏格兰时装出现。好吧，我们稍后会讨论苏格兰时装的问题。我的直觉是，你已经因为这个开始讨厌她了。
No, no, no, no. I'm objective. And you might think that, you know, the King of France's daughters would hate her, but not a bit of it, because the French princesses find her so charming, such fun, that they all end up the most tremendous pals. Oh, lovely. And in fact, I mean, particularly in Lady Antonia's biography, but more generally, the accounts of Mary Queen of Scots and her chums, you know, the French princesses and so on. It's like reading about the kind of the poshest, funnest boarding
不，不，不，不。我很客观。你可能会觉得，法国国王的女儿们会讨厌她，但一点也没有，因为法国公主们觉得她是如此迷人、如此有趣，以至于她们最终都成了极好的闺蜜。噢，太好了。事实上，尤其是在安东尼娅夫人的传记中，更广泛地说，关于苏格兰女王玛丽和她的闺蜜们（比如法国公主们等等）的记载，读起来就像是在看某种最高档、最有趣的寄宿学校小说。
school yarn. It's a kind of Renaissance Mallory towers. Right. And it's great fun, but there's also quite a lot of schooling. So Mary, like Elizabeth Tudor, her cousin over in England is given a very, very good education. I think it's fair to say that unlike Elizabeth, she's not an intellectual. Okay. But that's precisely what makes us so charming and fun because nobody likes an intellectual, do they? No, no, no one wants some blue stocking. No. So she's given an education that would conventionally be regarded as more appropriate to princes than princesses, but that's because she's a queen in her own right and so therefore she has to be prepared for her role. And as John Guy and his brilliant, I think, definitive biography of Mary Queen of Scots puts it, what she gets is the equivalent for a prospective
这简直是一种文艺复兴版的《马洛里之塔》（Mallory Towers）。没错，这非常有趣，但也伴随着相当多的学业。因此，玛丽和伊丽莎白·都铎（远在英国的堂姐）一样，接受了非常非常好的教育。我觉得可以公平地说，与伊丽莎白不同，她并不是一个知识分子。好吧。但恰恰是这一点让她如此迷人且有趣，因为没人喜欢知识分子，对吧？没错，没人想要什么蓝袜女（blue-stocking）。所以她接受的教育，按传统观念来看，似乎更适合王子而非公主，但这是因为她本身就是一位女王，因此她必须为自己的角色做好准备。正如约翰·盖伊在他那部极其精彩、堪称苏格兰女王玛丽决定性传记的著作中所说的那样，她所接受的教育，对于未来的统治者来说，就相当于
ruler of a degree in business administration. Okay. So she works hard, but not she's not a nerd. Right. Her real talent, much more I think than for kind of construing Livy or whatever, although she does that, is for having fun. So girls just want to have fun and Mary, Queen of Scots is the epitome of this. And it's such an amazing background for her because this of course is the golden age of the chateau in France. Anyone who's been to the Loire and seen the kind of the beautiful chateau there, this is what you're getting. And Mary and Francis and the royal princesses and all their friends are kind of endlessly processing from Fontainebleau outside Paris to Blois and to Chambord on the Loire.
一个工商管理学位。好吧。所以她学习很努力，但她不是书呆子。没错。她真正的天赋——比起什么解读李维（Livy）之类的好得多（尽管她确实也做这些）——其实是享受快乐。所以，女孩就是想快乐，而苏格兰女王玛丽就是这方面的化身。这为她提供了一个如此惊人的背景，因为这当然是法国城堡（chateau）的黄金时代。任何去过卢瓦尔河谷并看过那里美丽的城堡的人都会明白，这就是你所看到的。玛丽、弗朗西斯、皇家公主们以及他们所有的朋友，都在不断地从巴黎郊外的枫丹白露（Fontainebleau）前往布卢瓦（Blois），再前往卢瓦尔河畔的尚博尔（Chambord）进行巡游。
She visits them all. And Antonia Fraser can't get enough of it. So she exclaims, beautiful gardens, beautiful galleries, so many other beauties. Oh, how charming. But her biography is brilliant on this. I mean, it brilliantly evokes what she describes it as the kind of the dreamlike quality of Mary's upbringing in France. She's got ponies, of course. She's got lap dogs. She's got falcons. She has amazing clothes. I mean, the King of
她拜访了所有这些地方。安东尼娅·弗雷泽对此赞不绝口。于是她惊叹道：美丽的花园，美丽的画廊，还有那么多其他的美景。哦，多么迷人。但她的传记在这方面的描写极其精彩。我的意思是，它精彩地唤起了她所描述的玛丽在法国成长经历中那种“如梦似幻的特质”。她当然有小马。她有哈巴狗。她有猎鹰。她有惊艳的服饰。我的意思是，法国国王
France himself has said she has to have the best clothes possible. So she has gloves of dog skin and deer skin. She has velvet shoes of every conceivable color, you know, amazing gowns and dresses and trains, and she has so many jewels that she needs three brass chests just to hold them. So as I say, the most tremendous fun, But of course, you know, in boarding school stories, you're away from home. And so the issue of homesickness is always there. And so people may be wondering, well, Mary's a young girl who's gone to a foreign country. Is she ever homesick? And I think the answer to that is that to begin with, yes, she misses her mother very
本人曾说过，她必须穿尽可能最好的衣服。所以她有狗皮和鹿皮手套。她有各种你能想象到颜色的天鹅绒鞋子，你知道的，惊艳的礼服、裙装和超长拖尾，她拥有的珠宝多到需要三个黄铜箱子才能装下。所以正如我所说，这极其有趣，但是当然，你知道的，在寄宿学校的故事里，你远离了家。因此，思乡的问题总是存在的。所以人们可能会想，好吧，玛丽是一个去了异国他乡的小女孩，她会想家吗？我想答案是：一开始，是的，她非常思念她的母亲。
badly. And in fact, Mary of Guies will only once be able to make it out of Scotland and come and see her in France. And the reason for that is that she is literally holding the fort back in Scotland. You know, she's got Stirling Castle and she's surrounded by people who would quite like to see the back of her. And the person who particularly liked to see the back of her is the Earl of Arran, who is next in line to the Scottish throne and is this guy who is kind of endlessly shifting and running away from defeats and things like that. So Mary of Guise thinks he's a bit of a loser and she strikes in the spring of 1544 and
事实上，吉斯的玛丽一生中只有一次能够离开苏格兰去法国看望她。原因在于，她当时正 literalmente（字面意思）在苏格兰守卫大本营。（你知道的，她占据着斯特灵城堡，周围都是很想赶她走的人。）而特别想赶她走的人，是阿兰伯爵（Earl of Arran）。他是苏格兰王位的下一顺位继承人，这个人总是摇摆不定，一遇到失败就逃跑之类的。所以吉斯的玛丽觉得他有点像个失败者，于是在1544年春天，她采取了行动。
the reason that she does then is that by this point, her daughter, Mary Queen of Scots, is 12 years old and this is the kind of age when it's felt that she is able to kind of start picking up the reins of power. So Mary of Guise has prepared her tactic well. She's got people on side and she persuades Aaron to resign the regency in exchange for kind of various bungs and benefits and bribes. Mary of Guise, this foreign woman, takes his place as the Regent of Scotland. And of course, this is yet another consolidation of French control over Scottish affairs. And even as this is going on back in France, the Queen of Scots is becoming
她之所以在那个时候采取行动，是因为此时她的女儿、苏格兰女王玛丽已经12岁了，这正是人们认为她能够开始掌握权力缰绳的年龄。因此，吉斯的玛丽做好了策略准备。她争取到了支持者，并通过给予各种好处、福利和贿赂，说服阿兰辞去了摄政职务。吉斯的玛丽，这个外国女人，取代了他的位置，成为了苏格兰的摄政。当然，这又是法国对苏格兰事务控制的一次巩固。甚至在法国国内正在发生这一切的同时，苏格兰女王也
ever more of a French princess. Now you say that Tom, but am I not right in saying that she does dress sometimes in Scottish national dress to amuse the locals? So that's nice, isn't it? Yes. And this is defined in France as being basically animal skins, which is not Scottish national dress, but this is what they think. So it's a kind of mockery.
越来越像一位法国公主了。话虽如此，汤姆，难道我没说错吗：为了取悦当地人，她有时确实会穿苏格兰民族服装？所以这挺好的，对吧？是的。而在法国，这被定义为基本上是动物皮毛，这根本不是苏格兰民族服装，但这正是他们的想法。所以这是一种嘲讽。
Right. And she's complicit in it or are they dressing her up against her will or how does it work? A bit of both, I suspect. And I think it reflects the way in which Mary's links to Scotland are starting to fade as she becomes, you know, into her teenage years. So she had traveled to France with a substantial Scottish train. These are all the people who were seasick while she was being poised and regal and not being seasick on the journey. But most of her Scottish train has kind of been sent away. So the Scottish attendants who have come with her, when Mary's French grandmother,
没错。她是同谋，还是他们违背她的意愿给她穿上这些的？或者说这是怎么运作的？我猜两者都有吧。我认为这反映了随着玛丽进入青少年时期，她与苏格兰的联系开始逐渐淡化的方式。所以，她去法国时带了一个庞大的苏格兰随从团。这些人都是在她保持沉着优雅、在旅途中没有晕船时，却晕船的人。但她的大部分苏格兰随从都被遣散了。因此，那些和她一起来的苏格兰侍从，当玛丽的法国祖母——
her Guise grandmother, Antoinette de Guise comes across them, she's appalled. And she says, we can't have them. And her exact phrase is they are not as clean as they might be. So essentially, she's offended by Scottish standards of hygiene. Mary has a governess who herself is an illegitimate daughter of James the fourth and she's called Lady Fleming. She's stunningly gorgeous. So John Guy describes her as beautiful and voluptuous. And she was known by the French as La Belle Ecosse, so the beautiful Scotswoman. And she has a fling with Henry the second, the French king. And this in itself wouldn't have been particularly a problem except that she ends up pregnant and thereby precipitates a scandal.
她的吉斯祖母安托瓦内特·德·吉斯（Antoinette de Guise）遇到他们时，她感到震惊。她说：“我们不能留用他们。”她的原话是：“他们没有想象中那么干净。”从本质上讲，她被苏格兰人的卫生标准冒犯了。玛丽有一个家庭教师，她本身是詹姆斯四世的私生女，名叫弗莱明夫人（Lady Fleming）。她美得惊艳。因此，约翰·盖伊将其描述为美丽而妖娆。法国人称她为“美丽的苏格兰女人”（La Belle Ecosse）。她和法国国王亨利二世有一腿。这本身其实算不上什么大问题，但问题是她怀孕了，从而引发了一场丑闻。
And so she gets dismissed and sent back to Scotland in disgrace. However, it is not a completely Scott free zone because lady Fleming's daughter does remain with Mary in France. And she is one of four Scottish girls, all of Mary's age, all of noble birth, all called Mary, who constitute, I guess, I mean, we've now moved on from boarding school stories, these are now Mary's squad. This is like kind of gaggle of teenagers in Beverly Hills or whatever. So you've got the daughter of Lady Fleming, Mary Fleming.
于是她被解雇并带着耻辱被遣返回苏格兰。然而，这里并非完全没有苏格兰人，因为弗莱明夫人的女儿留在了法国陪伴玛丽。她是四位苏格兰女孩之一，和玛丽同龄，都出身贵族，名字都叫玛丽。她们构成了——我想，我们现在已经从寄宿学校的故事转变成了玛丽的“小团体”（squad）。这就像是比弗利山庄的一群青少年什么的。所以你有弗莱明夫人的女儿，玛丽·弗莱明（Mary Fleming）。
She's Mary Stewart's cousin. She is the highest ranking of all the four Marys. So you might call her posh Mary. Then there's Mary Livingston, who loves hunting, loves dancing, loves archery. So you might call her sporty Mary. Then there's Mary Beaton, who is the most beautiful. So you might call her sporty Mary. Then there's Mary Beaton, who is the most beautiful, so you might call her pretty Mary. And then there's Mary Seton, who knows all about clothes. She's brilliant at hairdressing. She can kind of tease any head of hair into
她是玛丽·斯图尔特的表妹。她是所有四个玛丽中地位最高的一个。所以你可能会叫她“高贵玛丽”。然后是玛丽·利文斯顿（Mary Livingston），她喜欢打猎、喜欢跳舞、喜欢射箭。所以你可以叫她“运动玛丽”。接着是玛丽·比顿（Mary Beaton），她是长得最漂亮的。所以你可以叫她“运动玛丽”。（注：原文此处有重复）然后是玛丽·比顿，她是长得最漂亮的，所以你大可以叫她“美貌玛丽”。最后是玛丽·西顿（Mary Seton），她精通各种服饰。她擅长美发，能把任何发型
an absolute miracle. So you might call her fashion Mary. And the five of them are completely inseparable and they get up to all kinds of scrapes and japes. And they're actually a bit like Peter the great and Marie Antoinette that they love playing at being common people. Okay. So to quote John Guy, Mary adored making cotton yak, a type of French marmalade, putting on an apron and boiling quinces and sugar with powder of violets in a saucepan for hours before laying out the slices of crystallized fruits. And she gets the four Marys to help her and they have a special kitchen that is kind of
梳成绝对的奇迹。所以你也许可以叫她“时尚玛丽”。这五个人形影不离，她们惹出了各种各样的恶作剧和麻烦。实际上，她们有点像彼得大帝和玛丽·安托瓦内特，她们喜欢假装成普通人。好吧。借用约翰·盖伊的话说，玛丽酷爱制作木瓜果酱（cotignac，一种法国果酱），系上围裙，在平底锅里熬煮榲桲和糖，加上紫罗兰粉，一煮就是几个小时，然后再把切片的蜜饯摆盘。她让四位玛丽来帮她，她们在自己的公寓里专门设立了一个厨房，系上围裙，假装成女仆或资产阶级妇女，组织家务和日常生活之类的事情。这一切都太有趣了。
created in their apartments and they put on aprons and pretend to be kind of servants or bourgeois women organizing, you know, the housework and the house routines and things like that. It's all such fun. Right. All very charming. And it does enable Mary Queen of Scots to keep up with her native language because she and the four Marys are all chattering
没错。非常迷人。这确实能让苏格兰女王玛丽保持她的母语，因为她和四个玛丽一直在用苏格兰语闲聊，尽管她们所有人此时都已经能说流利的法语，法语可能已经是她们的首选语言。但等到她十几岁时，我的意思是，她可能已经记不太清任何——我的意思是，她五岁离开时，大概对苏格兰一无所知，或者几乎一无所知。而这大概正是法国人想要的。他们希望她变成，你知道的，她是王太子的妻子，她将成为法国王后。他们实际上希望她变成法国人，对吗？嗯，具体来说是吉斯家族。所以她母亲那边的亲戚，因为
away in Scots, even though all of them by this point speak absolutely fluent French and probably it's their language of choice. But by the time she's in her mid-teens, I mean, she can probably barely remember any of, I mean, she left when she was five, she can probably remember nothing of Scotland or virtually nothing. And presumably that's what the French want. They want her to become, you know, she's the wife of the Dauphin, she's going to become the Queen of France. They effectively want her to be French, no? Well, and specifically the Guise family. So her relations on her mother's side, because
她绝对是吉斯家族计划的关键部分——不仅针对法国，也针对更广泛的欧洲。因此，当玛丽和她的雪地小马、做果酱等度过美好时光时，她的两个叔叔——我们之前提到过他们：现在是吉斯公爵的弗朗西斯（Francis）和洛林枢机主教查尔斯（Charles）——一直在忙于巩固他们对法国的控制。所以公爵的绰号是“刀疤脸”（Scarface）。他，你知道的，有战斗负伤。他很有魅力，但也很强硬，是一位参加过意大利战争的行动派老兵（正如我们在上一集所提到的），并且在1558年1月，他通过从英国人手中夺回加来、剥夺了英国人在法国本土的正当领地，而令自己名声大噪。
she is absolutely a key part of the Guise plans, not just for France, but for Europe more generally. So while Mary's been having this lovely time, you know, with her ponies and making marmalade and so on, her two uncles, we mentioned them before, Francis, who's now the Duke of Guise and Charles, who's the Cardinal of Lorraine, they've been busy consolidating their grip on France. So the Duke, his nickname is Scarface. He, you know, a battle injury. He's very charming, but he's also very hard nose, the man of action veteran of the Italian Wars, as we mentioned in the previous episode and a man who in January, 1558 shames himself by capturing Calais from the English, robbing them of their rightful possession on the French
所以这非常令人遗憾。还有那位枢机主教，正如我们所提到的，他是一位杰出且富有成效的阴谋家、法国宫廷的头号政治人物。他们两个让我想起雅各宾戏剧《马尔菲公爵夫人》（The Duchess of Malfi）中的公爵和枢机主教。我觉得他们身上有一种特质，传达了新教徒在这个时期对天主教势力和宫廷所感受到的一切阴暗面。没错。他们有一种“博吉亚家族”（Borgia）的气质。是的，绝对的。他们想要玛丽不仅是为了……如果玛丽和弗朗西斯有
mainland. So that's very sad. And the cardinal who is, as we mentioned, the kind of brilliant and fertile schemer, the leading political figure in the French court. And the pair of them remind me of the Duke and the cardinal in the Duchess of Malfi, the Jacobian drama. There's a kind of quality, I think, about them that conveys everything that Protestants tend to find sinister about Catholic powers and courts at this time. Right. They have a kind of Borgia vibe to them. Yes, exactly. And why they want Mary is not just to, you know, if Mary and Francis have
孩子，那么他们的孙辈将成为法国国王，大概是这样。但他们的野心远不止于此。他们想建立一个受他们控制的英法联合帝国。因此，他们一步步地在奠定基础。所以，他们将苏格兰女王玛丽掌握在手中；她的母亲、他们的姐妹吉斯玛丽作为摄政王统治着苏格兰；接着，在1558年4月24日，他们的侄女、苏格兰女王玛丽嫁给了王太子。玛丽在婚礼当天的早晨写信给远在苏格兰的母亲，她说道：“我能告诉你的是，我觉得自己是世界上最幸福的女人之一。”当然，她在婚礼上惊艳全场。非常令人震惊、非常具有创新性的是，她在婚礼上穿了一种完全新颖的颜色，那就是白色。
children then their grandchildren will be Kings of France, presumably. But their ambitions are higher than that. They want to forge a kind of Franco-British empire that will be under their thumb. And so step by step, they've been putting the building blocks in place. So they have Mary, Queen of Scots in their grasp. Her mother, their sister, Mary of Gies, is ruling Scotland as regent. And then on the 24th of April, 1558, their niece, Mary Queen of Scots, marries the Dauphin. And Mary writes to her mother back in Scotland on the morning of her marriage, and she says, all I can tell you is that I count myself one of the happiest women in the world. And of course, she's an absolute wow at the wedding. Very shockingly, very innovatively, she wears a completely novel color at her wedding, and that is white.
在法国，穿白色礼服是闻所未闻的，她这样做是因为她知道这最衬托她的肤色和她金棕色的头发。盛大的庆祝活动，金银币被抛向人群，婚礼宴席上有六艘巨大的机械船在宴会大厅里滑行，这一切都极其有趣、绝对精彩，每个人都度过了美妙的时光。那么，这场婚礼对苏格兰及其持续的独立意味着什么呢？所以从客观上、公众层面上看，似乎什么也没有。
In France, unheard of to wear a white dress, and she does this because she knows that it will suit her complexion and her urban hair. Great festivities, gold and silver coins tossed out into the crowds and the the wedding banquet features six giant mechanical ships that kind of glide around the the banqueting hall and it's all great fun and absolutely brilliant and everyone has a wonderful time. Now, what does this wedding mean for Scotland and its continued independence? So objectively, publicly, nothing it would seem.
所以在她结婚前九天，玛丽签署并盖章了一项承诺，宣誓维护——我引述一下——“苏格兰的自由、特权与特许权”。好吧。但在幕后，情况略有不同。就在她签署维护苏格兰独立保证书的前11天，玛丽拿到了另一份文件，这份文件是由她的吉斯叔叔们起草的，属于绝密。没有人谈论它。而且它是用非常浮夸的法律行话起草的，基本上是为了迷惑当时年仅15岁的玛丽。但当她在上面盖下玉玺时，她实际上是
So nine days before she gets married, Mary signs and seals a promise to uphold, and I quote, Scotland's freedoms, liberties and privileges. Okay. But behind the scenes, things are slightly different. So 11 days before she'd signed that pledge that Scottish independence will be maintained, Mary had been given another document that had been drawn up by her Guise uncles, which is top secret. Nobody talks about it. And it's been drawn up in very florid legal jargon, basically to kind of dazzle Mary who's still only 15 years old. But when she puts her seal to it, she is effectively
同意了一个完全具有爆炸性的承诺：如果苏格兰人民知道这件事，将会引发众怒。因为玛丽所说的是，如果她在没有继承人的情况下死去，那么她的丈夫弗朗西斯——大概他将成为法国国王，以及他所有的继承人，也就是所有未来的法国国王——也将同时统治苏格兰。因此苏格兰将成为法国某种封地的一部分。他们在文件中还写道：玛丽受到了如此出色的教育，你知道的，学习了她的商业研究之类的内容，骑着她的小马，戴着所有的狗皮手套等等。因此，苏格兰人为此欠法国一百万枚金币。所以这是一次非常昂贵的
agreeing to a completely bombshell promise that if people in Scotland knew about it would cause outrage. Because what Mary says is that if she dies without an heir, then her husband, Francis, that presumably he was going to become the King of France and all his successors, so all the future Kings of France will rule as well as the Kings of Scotland. So Scotland will become part of the French kind of fiefdoms. They also write in that Mary's have this wonderful education, you know, doing her business studies and stuff, all her ponies, all her dog skin gloves and everything. And that therefore the Scots owe France a million pieces of gold for it. So a very expensive
寄宿学校教育。而这实际上是将苏格兰变成法国一个省份的蓝图。法国人，天哪，谁能想到他们会表现得像毒蛇一样？而且最关键的是，这甚至还不是他们野心的极限，对吧？因为他们还……这才是真正令人震惊的事情——他们将目光投向了一个许多人会说是更宏大的奖项，那就是我们深爱的英国本土。难以置信。令人震惊。
boarding school education. And effectively it's a blueprint for turning Scotland into a province of France. The French, God, who would have thought that they would behave like such snakes? And here's the thing, they're not just, that's not even the limit of their ambitions, right? Because they're also, this is the really shocking thing, they have their eyes on a much greater prize, some would say, which is our own beloved country of England. Unbelievable. Shocking.
而且同样，玛丽是这个计划的关键，因为——我们还没触及这一点，但这是玛丽故事中非常非常重要的一部分。我们讨论过她是一个斯图尔特，即苏格兰王室血脉，但她的血管里也流淌着都铎家族（英国王朝）的血液。这是因为她的祖父詹姆斯四世（在弗洛登战役中阵亡的那个人）娶了亨利八世的姐姐玛格丽特，也就是玛格丽特·都铎。到1558年，也就是玛丽嫁给王太子的时候，这已经具有了潜在的巨大王朝意义。所以我们来看看离开时的英国：当时处于亨利八世年轻的新教继承人爱德华六世的统治之下，
And again, it's Mary who is the key to this plan because, and we haven't touched on this yet, but it's very, very important part of Mary's story. We've talked about how she's a Stuart, the Royal line of Scotland, but she also has the blood of the Tudors, the English dynasty in her veins. And this is because her grandfather, James IV, the guy who had died at the Battle of Flodden, he had married the sister of Henry VIII, Margaret, so Margaret Tudor. And by 1558, so when Mary is marrying the Dauphin, this has come to take on a potentially enormous dynastic significance. So we left England under the rule of Edward VI, the young Protestant heir
但他已于1553年去世，继位的是他的大姐、天主教徒玛丽·都铎（Mary Tudor）。然而她在玛丽·斯图尔特与王太子婚礼后的几个月里病倒了，而且可能是致命重病。因此，法国和英国都在提出的问题是，你知道的，如果玛丽·都铎去世了，谁将继承她的王位？
of Henry VIII, but he had died in 1553 and he'd been succeeded by his elder sister Mary Tudor, who is a Catholic. But she, in the months following Mary Stewart's wedding to the Dauphin, has fallen ill and potentially fatally ill. And so the question that is being asked in France as in England is, well, you know, if Mary Tudor dies, who is going to succeed her?
当然，她有一个小妹妹伊丽莎白，但伊丽莎白对英国王位的继承权在法国、特别是吉斯家族眼中是被轻蔑视之的。正如洛林枢机主教——法国宫廷里那个狡猾、甚至可以说是阴险的弄权者——所指出的那样：伊丽莎白是一个女巫的女儿，也就是被亨利八世处死的安妮·博林（Anne Boleyn），而且她的女儿伊丽莎白在1536年被议会法案宣布为私生子。所以在吉斯家族看来，她似乎被排除了在继承序列之外。更糟糕的是，当然，她是一个新教徒，没有哪个枢机主教认为一个新教徒应该继承（吉斯家族眼中的）英国王位。（注：原文此处有重复）
Now, of course, she has a younger sister, Elizabeth, but the claim of Elizabeth to the English throne is viewed in France and particularly by the Guise with contempt. So as the Cardinal of Lorraine, the subtle one might almost say sinister power player at the French court points out Elizabeth is the daughter of a witch namely Anne Boleyn who had been put to death by Henry VIII and her daughter Elizabeth had been declared a bastard by act of parliament in 1536. So she seems to be ruled out of the succession in the opinion of the Guise and worse than that of course she's a Protestant and no Cardinal is going to think that a Protestant should succeed to the throne of the Gays. And worse than that, of course, she's a Protestant and no
洛林枢机主教因此辩称，王位不应传给伊丽莎白，而应传给下一顺位继承人，而这个人恰好就是他自己的侄女玛丽·斯图尔特。所以这是令人震惊的事态发展。好吧。所以这潜在地——我的意思是，这将是重大的。我的意思是，这将使吉斯家族不仅控制一个王国，而是控制三个王国。
Cardinal is going to think that a Protestant should succeed to the throne of England. And so the Cardinal of Lorraine argues that the throne should not pass to Elizabeth, but instead to the next in line, who of course just happens to be his own niece, Mary Stuart. So shocking developments. Okay. So that is potentially, I mean, that would be momentous. I mean, that would give the Gies family control over not one kingdom, but three kingdoms.
因此，当玛丽——“血腥玛丽”玛丽·都铎于1558年11月17日去世时，他们立刻就介入了，对吧？他们说：“我们的侄女、苏格兰女王、法国的准王后，现在是英国的新女王了。”他们是认真的吗？我的意思是，这不仅是一种表演性的姿态，而是他们雄心壮志中严肃的一部分，是他们地缘政治野心的一部分，对吧？我认为他们是认真的，但当然其中确实带有一点表演性的成分，
And so when Mary, bloody Mary, Mary Tudor dies on the 17th of November, 1558, they're straight in there, aren't they? They say our niece, Mary, Queen of Scots, the Queen in waiting of France is now the new Queen of England. And they really mean this. I mean, this isn't just a performative gesture, that this is a serious part of their ambitions, of their kind of geopolitical ambition, right? I think they do mean it seriously, but of course there is a slightly performative element
因为他们想把玛丽当作英国女王来对待。因此，英国的纹章开始出现在法国和苏格兰纹章的旁边，你知道的，出现在王太子在他宫殿里使用的门廊、陶器和盘子上。当礼宾官为穿过城堡的玛丽·斯图尔特清道时，他们会大喊：“给英国女王让路！”这对玛丽来说显然是非常让人飘飘然的事情。我的意思是，太棒了。她是苏格兰女王，现在是英国女王，不久她将成为法国女王。那个时刻很快就到来了，因为在1559年7月10日，法国国王亨利二世因运动损伤而去世。
because they want to treat Mary as though she is the Queen of England. And so the English coat of arms starts featuring alongside those of France and Scotland, you know, in the doorways and the crockery and the plates and things that the dofan is using in his palace. And when ushers clear away for Mary Stewart, you know, going through the, the chateau or whatever, they are crying out, make way for the queen of England, which is obviously very heady stuff for Mary. I mean, brilliant. She's queen of Scots. She's now the queen of England. Soon she's going to be the queen of France. And that moment arrived very soon because on the 10th of July 1559, the French King Henry II dies of a sports
他在参加一场比武时，长矛穿过了头盔的缝隙刺入了眼睛，不久之后便去世了。两个月后的1559年9月15日，玛丽的丈夫加冕为法国国王。同样，玛丽在时尚上取得了巨大的成功。她身穿白色长袍，光彩夺目。王室的其他成员都穿着黑色，相比之下显得十分黯淡寒酸。而苏格兰女王——法国声称她是英国女王——现在也成为了法国女王。哇。借用约翰·盖伊的话说，无论法国宫廷在哪儿驻留、无论访问了哪座城镇，
injury. He's been in a tournament and the lance goes through a gap in his helmet into his eye and he dies very soon afterwards. And two months later on the 15th of September 1559, Mary's husband is crowned the King of France. And again, Mary is a massive fashion success. She wears white, she looks dazzling. All the other members of the royal family are in black, so they look very dowdy compared to her. And the Queen of Scots, who the French claim is the Queen of England, is now also the Queen of France. Wow. To quote John Guy, wherever the French court came to rest and whichever towns it visited,
弗朗西斯和玛丽的家族纹章都与英国的纹章一起醒目地绘制在城门上。所以她混得相当成功。苏格兰女王、法国女王、英国女王，而她当时大约16岁左右，非常迷人，诸如此类。我能在这个设计中看到的唯一微小瑕疵、苍蝇里的老鼠屎就是，她实际上并不是英国女王。不。所以这对她来说是个大问题，因为现在英国女王是她的表姐伊丽莎白·都铎。而这个人就是所有电影、书籍、歌剧等等里面她的死对头。你能理解为什么会这样，对吧？因为如果你是伊丽莎白一世，你一生都在
the heraldic arms of Francis and Mary were blazoned with those of England on the gates. So she has done very well for herself. Queen of Scots, Queen of France, Queen of England, and she's what about 16 or something and she's very glamorous and all this. The only slight flaw I can see in this fly in the in this design is that she's not actually the Queen of England. No. So this is a big problem for her because now the person who is the Queen of England is her cousin, Elizabeth Tudor. And this is the person who in all the films and the books and the operas and whatnot is her arch enemy. And you can see why that would be the case, right? Cause if you're Elizabeth the first and you've spent your life, you know, being
被宣布为私生子、被关在各种宅邸里诸如此类，而这个跨过海峡来到法国的新竞争对手的到来——她也同样迷人、野心勃勃——如果你是伊丽莎白，你大概会极其痛恨听到苏格兰女王玛丽的名字。嗯，我认为你最初的做法是确保欧洲各地的强权不承认这个对你王位构成潜在威胁的竞争对手。这正是伊丽莎白和她的外交官们所做的。因此，他们确保——例如，玛丽·都铎的丈夫、西班牙国王菲利普二世——承认伊丽莎白为女王。尽管菲利普是天主教徒而伊丽莎白是新教徒，菲利普二世
declared a bastard and being locked up in various houses and all of this, the arrival of this new contender over the channel in France, who's also very glamorous and wanna, if you're Elizabeth, you presume it'd be absolutely hate the very mention of Mary Queen of Scots's name. Well, I think that what you do initially is to ensure that powers across Europe do not recognize this potential rival to your throne. And this is exactly what Elizabeth and her diplomats do. So they ensure that, for instance, Mary Tudor's husband, who was the King of Spain, Philip the second, that he recognizes Elizabeth as queen. And even though Philip is Catholic and Elizabeth is Protestant, Philip the
确实承认了她。原因在于他极力想在与法国持续的斗争中拉拢英国。是的，当然。所以强权政治压倒了宗教信仰。这反过来意味着教皇必须承认伊丽莎白，因为教皇受制于菲利普二世。对。
second does recognize her. And the reason for that is that he's desperate to keep England on board in his ongoing struggle with France. Yeah, of course. So power politics trumps kind of religious affiliations. This in turn means that the Pope has to recognize Elizabeth because the Pope is under Philip the second's thumb. Yeah.
所以他必须照菲利普说的去做。而且，甚至连法国人自己也默认了这一点，因为在1559年4月2日，他们与英国签署了一项条约——《卡托-康布雷齐条约》（Treaty of Cateau-Cambresis）。这实际上就是那个条约。我的意思是，这有点复杂，但其实际效果是英国人承认他们失去了加来。作为交换，法国人默认接受了伊丽莎白是英国女王。这显然对玛丽是个可怕的消息，因为她对英国王位的宣称不仅被边缘化了，而且事实上与英国人签署这个条约的家伙正是她自己的叔叔吉斯家族——也就是那些曾经说过“你是英国女王”的人，因为正是
And so he has to do what, uh, what Philip says. And it's also implicitly agreed even by the French themselves, because on the 2nd of April, 1559, they sign a treaty with England, the Treaty of Catte-Cumbre-et-Si, which effectively is the treaty. I mean, it's kind of complicated, but in its practical effect is that the English acknowledge that they have lost Calais. And the quo for the quid is that the French implicitly accept that Elizabeth is Queen of England. And obviously this is terrible news for Mary because not only has her claim to the English throne been sidelined, but actually the guys who have signed this treaty with English are her own uncles, the Guise, the people who've been saying you're the Queen of England, because it was the
吉斯公爵攻占了加来，所以他想要确认自己的军事成就。这对玛丽来说是双重打击，因为所有对英国王位的宣称，正如你所说，疏远了伊丽莎白，但特别疏远了英国宫廷里的两个关键人物。其中一个是叫尼古拉斯·思罗克莫顿爵士（Sir Nicholas Throckmorton）的人，他是伊丽莎白驻法国的大使，是一位非常坚定、狂热的新教徒，因此极力反对英国再多一位天主教女王。他一直在忙着复印玛丽那些冒犯性的纹章。所以所有这些把英国的
Duke of Guise who had captured Calais and so he wants to confirm his military achievement. And it's doubly bad for Mary because all the kind of claims to the English throne, as you said, it's alienated Elizabeth, but it's particularly alienated two key operators at the English court. And one of these is a guy called Sir Nicholas Throckmorton, who is Elizabeth's ambassador to France, who is a very, very committed, hot Protestant and therefore very opposed to the idea of England having another Catholic queen. And he has been very busy making copies of Mary's offensive heraldic arms. So all these ones with England's, you know, the English
纹章与法国和苏格兰纹章并列的图案，他都复印并寄回伦敦。在那里，它们被伊丽莎白最信任的仆人、她的首席大臣威廉·塞西尔（William Cecil）所阅读。和思罗克莫顿一样，塞西尔是一位非常非常坚定的新教徒。他狂热地忠于伊丽莎白，但我可以说，他更狂热地忠于新教事业。他也是一个长期关注苏格兰事务的人，因为他曾与萨默塞特公爵爱德华·西摩（Edward Seymour）一起在平基战役（Battle of Pinky）中并肩作战——那场灾难性的惨败在某种程度上促成了玛丽前往法国。所以这两个能进言伊丽莎白的新教徒，
coat of arms being courted with the French and Scottish coat of arms. And he's sending them back to London. And there they are being read by Elizabeth's most trusted servant, her chief minister, who is a man called William Cecil, who like Throckmorton is a very, very committed Protestant. He's passionately loyal to Elizabeth, but even more passionately loyal, I would say, to the Protestant cause. And he's also a man who's long been interested in Scottish affairs because he had fought with Edward Seymour, the Duke of Somerset at the Battle of Pinky, the kind of the disastrous defeat that in a way had precipitated Mary going to France. So these two Protestants with the ear of Elizabeth,
他们痛恨玛丽，并将她视为对伊丽莎白以及英国新教事业的潜在致命威胁。因此，他们坚决致力于阻止天主教徒玛丽继承英国王位。他们是如此坚定，以至于塞西尔真正的野心不仅是阻止玛丽成为英国女王，还要将她从苏格兰王位上拉下来。所以玛丽对此一无所知，我认为她对此毫无觉察，但她已经树立了一个敌人——正如事实将证明的那样，这是一个和任何女王曾遇到过的一样狡猾且危险的敌人。而正当这一切发生时，苏格兰她的祖国也发生了动荡的事件。这些事件不仅威胁到苏格兰天主教的未来，也威胁到玛丽作为女王自身的存亡。汤姆，让我们在休息之后了解这些。好的。
they loathe Mary and they see her as a potentially mortal threat, not just to Elizabeth, but to the Protestant cause in England. And so they are completely committed to stopping the Catholic Mary ever succeeding to the English throne. And they're so committed to that that actually it's Cecil's real ambition is not just to stop Mary becoming Queen of England, but to topple her from her Scottish throne. So Mary, I think, is oblivious to this, but she has made herself an enemy who, as events will prove, is as subtle and dangerous an enemy as any Queen could have. And while this has been going on, of course, there have been tumultuous events in Scotland back in her homeland. Events that threaten not just the future of Catholicism in Scotland, but Mary's own survival as Queen. Tom, let's find out about those after the break. Let's.
8月1st，我可以直言不讳吗？我更喜欢英语。让我们在休息之后了解这些。好的。隆重推出 TurboTax Business，一种为您自己申报 T2 报税表的全新品类方式，同时还能获得真正精通小企业的专家的帮助。经营着一家纹身店、玩具店、还是微小而强大的塔可摊？我们有精通小企业税务内外的专家。专家随时准备在您报税时提供帮助和审核，确保您的报税表准确无误。Intuit TurboTax Business，TurboTax Canada 的全新产品。适用部分地区限制。访问 TurboTax Business 了解更多。TurboTax Canada 的全新产品。适用部分地区限制。访问 TurboTax.ca/businesstax 了解更多。我是大卫·乌利肖格。
On August 1st, may I speak freely? I prefer English. Let's find out about those after the break. Let's. Introducing TurboTax Business, a brand new way to file your own T2 return, all while getting help from an expert who actually knows small businesses. Got a tattoo studio, toy store, tiny but mighty taco stand? We've got someone who gets small business taxes inside and out. Experts are standing by to help and review while you file, so you know your return's done right. Intuit TurboTax Business, new from TurboTax Canada. Some regional exclusions apply. Learn more at TurboTax Business. New from TurboTax Canada. Some regional exclusions apply. Learn more at TurboTax.ca slash business tax. I'm David Ullishogger.
我是萨拉·丘奇韦尔。我们是《穿越时空之旅》的共同主持人，在这里，我们将通过亲历者的视角，探索历史上最黑暗的时刻。今天，我们将为您讲述关于伦敦大火的新系列——17世纪重大的转折点事件之一，也是整个英国和不列颠历史上最重要的事件之一。它始于布丁巷的一家面包店，并迅速演变成一场灾难。它吞噬了13,000栋房屋，摧毁了伦敦，按今天的货币计算，造成了100亿英镑的损失。它甚至烧毁了标志性的圣保罗大教堂。这座城市已经饱受大疫灾的蹂躏，但外敌入侵的谣言导致暴徒在街头袭击无辜的外国人。
And I'm Sarah Churchwell. Together we're the hosts of Journey Through Time, where we explore the darkest steps of history through the eyes of the people who live through it. Today, we're going to tell you about our new series on the Great Fire of London, one of the great pivotal events of the 17th century, one of the most important events in all of English and British history. It began at a bakery on Pudding Lane and quickly turned into a catastrophe. It consumed 13,000 houses, decimated London and caused 10 billion pounds worth of damage in today's money. It even burned down the iconic St. Paul's Cathedral. The city was already devastated by the Great Plague, but rumors of foreign invasion led mobs to attack innocent foreigners on the streets.
在本集中，我们将探讨谣言、假新闻和仇外心理带来的令人不寒而栗的后果——这些问题显然并非今天所独有。从拼命拯救家园和财物，到引发致命后果的责任推卸之争，这是大火中底层民众亲历的故事，也是它留给这座城市的持久影响。我们在本集末尾有一个简短的片段。本集末尾。去推举一个女人来承担统治、优越、统治权或帝国，凌驾于任何王国、国家之上，
In this episode, we'll explore the chilling consequences of rumors of fake news, of xenophobia, problems that clearly are not unique to today. From desperate attempts to save their homes and belongings, to the struggle to assign blame which turned deadly. This is the story of the fire as it was lived through by the people on the ground and the lasting impacts it left on the city. We've got a short clip at the end of this episode. end of this episode. To promote a woman to bear rule, superiority, dominion, or empire above any realm, nation,
在本期节目中，我们将探讨假新闻谣言和仇外心理带来的令人心寒的后果，这些问题显然并非当今所独有。从拼命试图拯救家园和财物，到演变成致命的追责斗争。这就是亲历这场火灾的当地民众所经历的故事，以及它对这座城市留下的持久影响。我们在本期节目最后有一小段剪辑。本期节目结束。为了提升女性统治、优越、统治或帝国的权力，凌驾于任何王国、国家之上，
or city is repugnant to nature. It's contumely to God a thing most contrary to his revealed will and approved ordinance. And finally, it's the subversion of good order of all equity and justice. Now that was an archive recording of a Scot, an author of one of the most famous pamphlets ever written by a Scot. I mean, history is littered with famous pamphlets, but this is probably the most famous and it's the first blast of the trumpet against the monstrous regiment of women. And disappointingly, monstrous regiment there actually means the kind of unnatural rule of women. I'd always thought of it as being, you know, a military squad of women with bayonets marching
或者城市，这是对自然的大不敬，是对上帝的亵渎，与其天启的意志和认可的法令背道而驰。最后，它是对良好秩序以及所有公平正义的颠覆。刚才那是一段苏格兰人的历史录音，他是一位由苏格兰人撰写的最著名小册子的作者。我的意思是，历史上充斥着各种著名的小册子，但这可能是最著名的一本，它就是《对女性怪异统治的第一次号角痛击》。令人失望的是，其中的“怪异统治”实际上指的是女性不自然的反常统治。我以前一直以为，你知道的，那是一支拿着刺枪、迈着正步走向大炮什么的女性军事小分队。现在，这位作者正如你在笔记中描述的那样，Tom，顶级女权主义者兼乐天派，约翰·诺克斯。所以他是苏格兰宗教改革的伟大教父。他极其痛恨苏格兰女王玛丽，对吧？是的，他的确如此。但他真正的主张是，在1558年他写下那本小册子的时候，女王并不是他真正的目标。他的目标是另有其人。玛丽·T，那本小册子，女王并不是他真正的目标。他的目标是另有其人。
towards cannon or something. Now it's an author you describe in your notes, Tom, as top feminist and funster, John Knox. So he's the great sort of godfather of the Scottish Reformation. He absolutely hates Mary Queen of Scots, doesn't he? Yeah, he does. He does. But here's the thing, his target in 1558 when he wrote that pamphlet, she wasn't really his target there. His target was somebody else. Mary T that pamphlet, she wasn't really his target there. His target was somebody else.
或者说，是他笔记中提到的约翰·诺克斯。那么，他是苏格兰宗教改革的伟大教父。他极其痛恨苏格兰女王玛丽，对吧？是的，他的确如此。但他真正的主张是，在1558年他写下那本小册子的时候，玛丽并不是他真正的目标。他的目标是另有其人。
Mary Tudor in England and Mary of Gies in Scotland, right? Yeah, principally Mary Tudor. He basically doesn't like Mary's. Yeah, it's not just women, it's Mary's. He's not in favour of them at all. And he sees definitely Mary Tudor, but also by extension Mary of Gies as kind of exercising a Catholic tyranny over the whole of Great Britain.
英格兰的玛丽·都铎和苏格兰的吉斯的玛丽，对吧？是的，主要是玛丽·都铎。他基本上就是不喜欢叫玛丽的人。是的，不仅仅是女人，而是叫玛丽的人。他一点也不支持她们。他明确认为，玛丽·都铎，还有引申出来的吉斯的玛丽，正在对整个大不列颠实行一种天主教暴政。
And so that pamphlet is a kind of pain cry of despair and frustration that Catholic rule under these women seems impregnable and that the reformation threatens to be stillborn in the island. And yet Dominic, you as a bluff Protestant will be thrilled to learn that only two years later, everything had been stood on its head. Okay. So by 1560, the authority of the Catholic church in Scotland has been toppled. And actually, as it turns out, decisively defeated, Protestant reformers like Knox himself, perhaps preeminently Knox himself, have emerged triumphant. And the measure of what Scotland has gone through in those two years is that Alec Reiry, the great historian of British Protestantism in his book, The Origins of the Scottish Reformation. He can describe those two years as not just one of the most extraordinary
所以那本小册子是一种绝望和挫败的痛苦呐喊，因为这些女性统治下的天主教政权似乎坚不可摧，宗教改革面临着在这个岛屿上胎死腹中的危险。然而，多米尼克，你作为一个直率的新教徒，一定很高兴得知仅仅两年后，一切都彻底颠覆了。好吧。到了1560年，天主教会在苏格兰的权威已经被推翻。事实上，事实证明，这是决定性的失败，像诺克斯本人这样的新教改革者，也许最杰出的就是诺克斯本人，已经取得了胜利。苏格兰在那两年里所经历的变革之大，正如英国新教的伟大历史学家亚历克·里里在他的著作《苏格兰宗教改革的起源》中所说的那样。他将这两年形容为不仅是欧洲历史上最非凡的
national transformations in European history, but he goes on to say that it's arguably the first modern revolution. He disagrees with you because you claim the first modern revolution took place hundreds of years earlier and yet he's a famous professor, Tom. How could you explain that? I think what he probably means there is the first revolution of modern Europe, which is a slightly different way of phrasing it. Is that what it is? I think that is what it is. So people may be wondering what on earth has happened? What
国家转型之一，而且他接着说，这可以说是第一场现代革命。他不同意你的观点，因为你声称第一场现代革命发生在几百年前，然而他是一位著名的教授，Tom。你怎么解释这一点？我想他大概的意思是现代欧洲的第一场革命，这是稍微不同的表述方式。是这样吗？我想这就是那个意思。所以人们可能想知道这到底发生了什么？这
is this great revolution? And I guess that as good a way as any of answering that question is to look at the career up until this point of John Knox, who was probably the most famous of all Mary Stuart's adversaries. And so he, like so many of the early Protestants, I mean, there's such a feature of the series we did on Martin Luther, he had originally himself been a Catholic priest, and probably he was converted to Protestantism by Patrick Hamilton, who we mentioned in the previous episode was Scotland's first Protestant martyr. He'd been burnt at St Andrews in 1546. And the man who presided over that execution, who'd brought Hamilton to trial and then convicted him, and then set him up on a stake in St Andrews, strapped with bags of gunpowder. This was
是一场什么样的大革命？我想回答这个问题最好的方法之一，就是回顾一下约翰·诺克斯到目前为止的职业生涯，他可能是玛丽·斯图亚特所有对手中最著名的一个。所以他，就像早期的新教徒一样——这也是我们制作的关于马丁·路德的系列节目的一个重要特色——他最初本身是一名天主教神父，他很可能是被帕特里克·汉密尔顿转化为新教徒的，我们在上一集提到过，帕特里克·汉密尔顿是苏格兰第一位新教殉道者。他于1546年在圣安德鲁斯被火刑处死。而主持那场处决的人，也就是把汉密尔顿交付审判、定罪，然后把他绑在圣安德鲁斯的火刑柱上、身上缠满火药袋的人，就是
Scotland's leading churchman, a guy called David Beaton, who was the Archbishop of St Andrews, but was also Scotland's last cardinal, as it will prove. And three months later, Beaton gets killed by five assassins who were out to revenge themselves on Beaton for the death of Patrick Hamilton. And they murder him in his own stronghold, the castle of St. Andrews, which is right on the coast, pretty impregnable. And they hang his body from the castle walls. It's been stripped naked. Then they pull it down. One of the Protestants who've kind of gathered around to exalt over his humiliation then urinates in the mouth of the corpse. They then salt his body and they throw it into the most notorious dungeon
苏格兰的主要教会领袖，一个叫大卫·比顿的人，他是圣安德鲁斯的大主教，但也将成为苏格兰的最后一位红衣主教。三个月后，比顿被五名刺客杀死，这些刺客是为了给帕特里克·汉密尔顿的死复仇而寻找比顿的。他们在比顿自己的据点圣安德鲁斯城堡谋杀了比顿，这座城堡就位于海岸边，可以说是坚不可摧。他们把比顿的尸体剥光了衣服，悬挂在城堡的城墙上。然后他们把尸体拉下来。一个聚集在周围庆祝比顿蒙羞的新教徒竟然对着尸体的嘴小便。然后他们把他的尸体用盐腌起来，扔进了整个苏格兰最臭名昭著的地牢里
in the whole of Scotland, which is inside the castle of St Andrews. And it's a very deep bottle shaped hole. So once you've been put in it, you can only be got out with a kind of rope and it's dug below the level of the sea right next to the, you know, where you can kind of hear the distant booming of the waves through the rock. And this is, you know, a pointed humiliation of the preeminent Catholic churchmen in Scotland. And yet also a fairly standard night out in St Andrews, I would say. Yeah, well, students at St Andrews can take us up on that. So Knox is obviously thrilled by this. He's one of the Protestants who goes to the castle of St. Andrews, which is now kind of stronghold of Protestantism. He serves the garrison there as its chaplain and they're able very easily to hold out
，那个地牢就在圣安德鲁斯城堡内部。那是一个非常深的瓶状洞穴。所以一旦你被放进去，只能用一根绳子才能把你拉出来，而且它是挖在海平面以下，紧挨着，你知道的，在那里你可以通过岩石听到远处的波涛轰鸣声。这是一个，你知道的，对苏格兰最显赫天主教教会领袖的尖锐羞辱。然而，这也是圣安德鲁斯相当标准的一个夜晚外出活动，我想是这样的。是的，好吧，圣安德鲁斯的学生们可以去体验一下。所以诺克斯对此显然欣喜若狂。他是前往圣安德鲁斯城堡的新教徒之一，该城堡现在是新教的一个据点。他作为那里的随军牧师为守军服务，他们非常轻松地就能抵挡住
against the Scottish authorities up until the point when Henry II sends a massive task force to Scotland to try and throw the English out. And this task force has enough men that they can go and capture the castle of St Andrews and all the garrison are taken prisoner and they are sent to the galleys and Knox is among them. So he gets chained up on the bench, he has to pull the oars and so on. And he does this for a year and a half. And finally, he is set free as a result of a personal intervention from the English Protestant King Edward VI, who admires John Knox. So Knox is set free, can't go back to Scotland, so he goes to England.
苏格兰当局的进攻，直到亨利二世派遣了一支庞大的特遣队到苏格兰试图把英国人赶出去。这支特遣队有足够多的人手去攻占圣安德鲁斯城堡，所有的守军都被俘虏了，他们被送去划船，诺克斯也在其中。所以他被锁在长凳上，不得不拉动船桨等等。他这样做了好几年。最后，由于英国新教国王爱德华六世的亲自干预，他被释放了，爱德华六世很欣赏约翰·诺克斯。所以诺克斯被释放了，不能回苏格兰，于是他去了英格兰。
He's given a parish in Newcastle, which he chooses because it's pretty close to Scotland. And so Protestant refugees can kind of amass there. It becomes a kind of center of resistance to Mary of Guise and her Catholic regime in Scotland. And Knox thinks Edward VI is brilliant. He thinks England is brilliant. He sees it as, you know, the New Jerusalem. Brilliant. It's absolutely wonderful. Hooray. And then, of course,
他在纽卡斯尔得到一个教区，他选择这里是因为它离苏格兰很近。因此新教难民可以聚集在那里。它成为了对抗吉斯的玛丽和她在苏格兰的天主教政权的一个抵抗中心。诺克斯认为爱德华六世棒极了。他认为英格兰棒极了。他认为这就是，你知道的，新耶路撒冷。太棒了。这绝对太美妙了。万岁。然后，当然，
Edward VI dies and is succeeded by Mary Tudor, who is Catholic, who will go on to be called by Protestants Bloody Mary because of her burning of Protestants. And so Knox thinks, ah, this isn't a good place for me. And so he scrams and he ends up in Switzerland in Geneva, which has become a kind of godly city of reformed religion under the aegis of John Calvin with Luther, one of the two great figures of the Protestant Reformation. And if Knox had thought that England was brilliant, he thinks that Geneva is even better. So he described it famously as the most perfect school of Christ that ever was in the earth since the days of the apostles.
爱德华六世去世了，继位的是天主教徒玛丽·都铎，由于她火烧新教徒，后来被新教徒称为“血腥玛丽”。所以诺克斯心想，啊，这地方对我不妙。于是他溜之大吉，最后来到了瑞士日内瓦。在约翰·卡尔文的庇护下，日内瓦已经变成了一个信奉归正宗教的圣洁城市。卡尔文与路德一起，是新教改革的两位伟大人物之一。如果说诺克斯之前觉得英格兰很棒的话，他觉得日内瓦甚至更好。因此他有一句名言，将其描述为“自从使徒时代以来，大地上曾有过的最完美的基督学校”。
Lucky. But he does go back to Scotland from times time, doesn't he? A couple of times he goes back, yeah. Yeah, because there's now a sort of coterie of Scottish lords who are prepared to protect him. And is that because they are Protestants themselves now? Yes. Right. So basically the Reformation has swept through Scotland, including the kind of the aristocratic hierarchy.
真幸运。但他确实不时回苏格兰，对吧？他回去过几次，是的。是的，因为现在有一小批苏格兰贵族准备保护他。这是因为他们自己现在成了新教徒吗？是的。没错。所以基本上宗教改革席卷了苏格兰，包括贵族阶层。
Yes. And in fact, the most significant of these is Mary Stuart's own half brother, so one of the many illegitimate sons that her father James V had fathered. And he also is James, so James Stewart, Lord James Stewart. He's often cast as a kind of Machiavellian, and he's certainly, he's kind of a very subtle man, he's certainly capable of incredible duplicity, but he is also very sober minded and I think very devoutly Protestant. So all his kind of his political maneuvering is, I think, in the cause of very strongly held Protestant convictions. And so Jenny Wermald, the great Scottish historian who's very down on Mary Stuart, she loves her half brother. She thinks that Lord James Stuart is brilliant, describes him as a true
是的。事实上，其中最重要的人物是玛丽·斯图亚特同父异母的兄弟，也就是她的父亲詹姆斯五世生下的众多私生子之一。他也是詹姆斯，也就是詹姆斯·斯图亚特，詹姆斯·斯图亚特勋爵。他经常被塑造成一个类似马基雅维利式的人物，他当然也是一个非常狡猾的人，他绝对有能力做出令人难以置信的两面派行为，但他也非常头脑清醒，我认为他有着非常虔诚的新教信仰。因此，我认为他所有的政治谋略都是为了坚定不移的新教信念。所以珍妮·沃莫尔德，这位对玛丽·斯图亚特非常严厉的伟大苏格兰历史学家，她非常喜爱玛丽同父异母的兄弟。她认为詹姆斯·斯图亚特勋爵非常了不起，把他描述为一个真正的
Stuart, tough, able, masterful, self-interested. And I guess by implication, she's implying that Mary Stewart is none of those things. And he's great pals with Cecil, isn't he, with the guy who's going to become Elizabeth the First's great spymaster. So this is a really important axis in Mary's story. Yes. And so this guy who in due course will become the Earl of Moray, and that's the name by which he's better known, he's a key player in the story of Mary, Queen of Scots. And so he is able to provide patronage to Protestants in Scotland. But it's also because Mary of Gies, who's the Regent, even though she's Catholic, I mean, she's not a natural fanatic. She's not a Mary Tudor. Her priority, I think, is to keep Scotland
斯图亚特人，强硬、能干、富有掌控力、利己。我想弦外之音是，她暗示玛丽·斯图亚特没有这些特质。而且他和塞西尔关系很好，对吧，就是那个即将成为伊丽莎白一世的伟大间谍头子的人。所以这是玛丽故事中一个非常重要的轴心。是的。因此，这个日后将成为莫雷伯爵的人（这也是他更广为人知的名字）是苏格兰女王玛丽故事中的关键人物。因此，他能够为苏格兰的新教徒提供庇护。但这也是因为身为摄政王的吉斯的玛丽，尽管她是天主教徒，我的意思是，她并不是一个天生的狂热分子。她不是玛丽·都铎。我认为她的首要任务是确保苏格兰的安全，为了她的女儿苏格兰女王玛丽、她的王朝吉斯家族、她的国家法国。如果这意味着对新教徒做出一些妥协，那么她很乐意这么做。我认为，她为维护苏格兰正统天主教信仰而做出的承诺在她的清单上只能排到第四位。好吧。但随后，可以想象的是，改变一切的是1558年玛丽·都铎的去世以及伊丽莎白成为英格兰女王的事实。因为玛丽不是一个老妇人，所以她本可以再活10年或20年。这是玛丽·都铎，再活10年或20年。但随着她的去世和伊丽莎白的继位，
secure for her daughter, Mary, Queen of Scots, her dynasty, the Guises, her country, France. And if that means cutting a bit of slack to Protestants, then she's happy to do that. Her commitment to preserving Scotland for the true Catholic faith is kind of fourth on the list, I would say. Okay. But then, presumably, what changes everything is the death of Mary Tudor in 1558 and the fact that Elizabeth becomes the Queen of England. Because Mary was not an old woman, so she could have lived for 10 or 20 years. This is Mary Tudor, 10 or 20 years more. But with her death and the accession of Elizabeth,
为她的女儿、苏格兰女王玛丽、她的王朝吉斯家族以及她的祖国法国争取保障。如果这意味着对新教徒做出一些让步，那么她很乐意这样做。我认为，她对为真正的天主教信仰保护苏格兰的承诺在她的清单上大概排在第四位。好的。但随后，大概改变一切的是1558年玛丽·都铎的逝世，以及伊丽莎白成为英格兰女王的事实。因为玛丽并不是一个老妇人，所以她本可以再活10年或20年。这是玛丽·都铎，再活10年或20年。但随着她的逝世和伊丽莎白的即位，
the whole kaleidoscope takes another turn. Well, why does it take such a turn? Is it basically because England now between Scotland and France is ideologically different and therefore there's a new impetus towards Protestantism in Scotland. Why does Elizabeth's succession make such a difference to the story? Having a Protestant on the English throne obviously is a massive destabilizing factor, certainly for Mary of Guise. And the reason that it's a disaster is that it goes with the grain of trends within Scotland. Her rule, although it's been very competent and although she's a very effective political operator, she is French and this has become increasingly unpopular with large swathes of Scottish public opinion and particularly
整个万花筒又迎来了另一个转折。那么，为什么会有这样的转折呢？基本上是因为现在处于苏格兰和法国之间的英格兰在意识形态上有所不同，因此苏格兰内部出现了转向新教的新动力。为什么伊丽莎白的继位对这个故事产生了如此大的影响？英格兰王位上坐着一位新教君主，这显然是一个巨大的破坏稳定的因素，对吉斯的玛丽来说尤其如此。之所以这是一场灾难，是因为它顺应了苏格兰国内的发展趋势。她的统治虽然非常称职，而且她是一个非常高效的政治操盘手，但她是法国人，这在苏格兰广大公众舆论中，尤其是
with the Scottish nobility. And so by the time that Elizabeth becomes Queen in England, there are nobles in Scotland who are starting to think that France is playing the role in the national demonology that the English traditionally have played. So there is one resentful Lord describes the alliance with France, the old alliance, as an iron hook that have caught and killed for now the most part of our ancestors, which is a kind of massive rewriting of history. And part of the reason for this isn't just dislike for the kind of heavy-handed character of the French garrisons that are providing Mary of Guise with her muscle in Scotland.
在苏格兰贵族中，越来越不受欢迎。因此，当伊丽莎白在英格兰成为女王时，苏格兰的一些贵族开始认为，法国在苏格兰的民族恶魔学中扮演着传统上由英国人扮演的角色。因此，有一位满腹怨气的贵族将与法国的同盟（即“老同盟”）描述为“一个铁钩，已经勾住并残害了我们祖宗的大多数人”，这可以说是对历史的大规模篡改。造成这种局面的部分原因，不仅仅是因为厌恶为吉斯的玛丽在苏格兰提供武力的法国驻军那种简单粗暴的作风，
It's also that she is trying to provide Scotland with the kind of centralised rule that she, as a French aristocrat, takes for granted. She thinks this is what is required for a successful modern state. And again, Scottish nobles feel resentful of this. They feel kind of cut off from her patronage. They feel that the traditional roads by which they can source power are being closed off to her. And then on top of that, there's the continued presence of their own queen, so Mary Stuart, Mary of Guise's daughter, in France, which is, I think, experienced by many Scots, not as redounding to Scotland's glory, but as a national humiliation. And we talked about this when we did
还在于她正试图为苏格兰提供一种她作为法国贵族认为理所当然的集权统治。她认为这是一个成功的现代国家所必需的。同样，苏格兰贵族对此感到不满。他们觉得自己被她的庇护所抛弃了。他们觉得他们获取权力的传统途径正在被她关闭。不仅如此，他们自己的女王——也就是玛丽·斯图亚特，吉斯玛丽的女儿——仍然留在法国，在许多苏格兰人看来，这并非为苏格兰增光，而是一种民族羞辱。我们在谈论
Marie Antoinette, the way in which often foreign queens in France are kind of hostages. You know, they're held there in a gilded cage to ensure good behaviour from the country that the queen has come from. So a group of these guys have already formed, I mean, I'll tell you what they love in Scotland. They love a covenant. They can't get enough of a covenant. Covenants like tea cakes, iron brew, they love all that. They've pledged themselves to the reformation and with the arrival of Elizabeth, these sort of these people, what do they call themselves? The Lords of the congregation.
玛丽·安托瓦内特时也讨论过这一点，法国的外国王后往往就像人质一样。你知道的，她们被囚禁在金丝雀笼里，以确保王后来时的那个国家行为端正。因此，这群家伙中已经有一部分人结成了同盟——我的天，我告诉你苏格兰人有多爱誓约。他们对誓约简直爱不释手。誓约就像茶饼、Irn-Bru（苏格兰国民饮料）一样，他们爱极了这一切。他们发誓效忠宗教改革，而随着伊丽莎白的到来，这些人——他们自称什么来着？——公国贵族议会。
Yeah. They now think brilliant. They've got a Protestant monarch in England and we can actually use this now. The time has come to kick the French out of Scotland and actually to completely turn the Alliance system on its head and to have an ideologically based Protestant Alliance with the old enemy with the English. Yes, and Dominic, you might say the kindling has been laid, but the spark needs to be provided. And the spark is provided by the return to Scotland on the 2nd of May 1559 of John Knox. And I think it's fair to say that just as Mary of Guise is kind of unsettled by the accession of Elizabeth in England, so also ironically, it's John Knox,
是的。他们现在觉得太棒了。他们在英格兰有了一位新教君主，我们现在真的可以利用这一点了。把法国人赶出苏格兰的时机已经成熟，实际上还要彻底颠覆同盟体系，与老敌人英国人结成意识形态上的新教同盟。是的，多米尼克，你可能会说干柴已经铺好，但还需要一颗火星。而这颗火星是由约翰·诺克斯在1559年5月2日返回苏格兰点燃的。而且我认为可以说，正如吉斯的玛丽因伊丽莎白在英格兰继位而感到寝食难安一样，具有讽刺意味的是，约翰·诺克斯也是如此，
because John Knox is actually very, very pro-English. He had wanted to go to England rather than to Scotland because he thought that the English were naturally much holier, always very grateful to Edward VI, always kind of held a candle for England. But it's unfortunately, his blast of the trumpet against the Montres Regiment of Women, which he had targeted against Mary Tudor, comes out just as Mary dies and is succeeded by the Protestant Elizabeth. And Elizabeth is massively offended by it. To be fair, you can see why. I mean, of course you can. And so she bans Knox from England. And so, Fote de Muir, Knox ends up going to Scotland. So Knox actually, ironically, is a bit like Mary. His loyalties primarily are to a foreign country. Knox would rather be in England,
因为约翰·诺克斯实际上非常非常亲英。他本想去英格兰而不是苏格兰，因为他认为英国人天生要虔诚得多，一直对爱德华六世充满感激，对英格兰一直抱有好感。但不幸的是，他针对玛丽·都铎撰写的《对女性怪异统治的第一次号角痛击》，偏偏在玛丽去世、新教徒伊丽莎白继位之际出版了。伊丽莎白对此感到极为冒犯。平心而论，你可以理解为什么。我的意思是，你当然能理解。因此她禁止诺克斯进入英格兰。于是，在别无选择的情况下，诺克斯最终去了苏格兰。所以，讽刺的是，诺克斯其实有点像玛丽。他们的忠诚首先是对着一个外国。诺克斯宁愿呆在英格兰，
Mary would rather be in France, but they both end up in Scotland. And Knox's arrival in Scotland, as I said, has this kind of incendiary impact. So in Perth, he gives a brilliantly inflammatory sermon that sets mobs roaming the city, attacking the city's monasteries, gives another sermon in St Andrews and the congregation rush out and start disassembling the local cathedral. And all across Scotland, he inspires these kind of waves of godly vandalism. Abbey's a strip bear and people go into the orchards of friaries and chop them down and take all the apples. And my favorite detail is that lots of godly reformers go into the gardens kept by the monks and literally pull up all the flowers by hand. These flowers are offensive unto the eyes of the Lord. And I guess the key
玛丽宁愿呆在法国，但他们最终都来到了苏格兰。正如我所说，诺克斯抵达苏格兰产生了这种具有煽动性的影响。因此在珀斯，他发表了一篇极其煽动性的布道，引发暴民在城里游荡，袭击城市的修道院；在圣安德鲁斯又发表了一篇布道，会众们冲出去开始拆卸当地的大教堂。在整个苏格兰，他激起了这类圣洁破坏公物的浪潮。修道院被洗劫一空，人们走进修道院的果园把果树砍倒，拿走所有的苹果。我最喜欢的细节是，许多圣洁的改革者走进僧侣们打理的花园，字面意义上用手把所有的花都连根拔起。这些花在主的眼里是十恶不赦的。我想，关键的
indicator that Nox and the Lords of the Congregation have I guess the key indicator that Knox and the Lords of the Congregation have the wind in their sails comes when the Earl of Arran, who we've been fingering throughout the story as Scotland's supreme trimmer, a guy who's constantly responding to the blowing of the wind, he changes sides. So initially he'd been a supporter of Mary of Guise, then by September 1559 he thinks, oh, it's all up with her, I'm going to switch sides. And he brings over a whole other swathe of the Scottish nobles. So that by October, most of the lords in certainly in the Scottish lowlands, it's different in the highlands, which of course is that
迹象——诺克斯和公国贵族议会大权在握的关键迹象，出现在阿伦伯爵倒戈之时。我们在整个故事中一直指出阿伦伯爵是苏格兰最大的墙头草，是一个不断根据风向调整自己的人，他改变了立场。最初他是吉斯的玛丽的支持者，但到了1559年9月，他觉得，哦，她彻底完蛋了，我要叛变了。他拉拢了苏格兰贵族的另一大批人。因此到了10月，苏格兰低地的绝大多数贵族（高地则不同，高地当然
much more remote, but most of the lords in the Scottish lowlands are openly ranged against Mary of Gies, the French regent. And in fact, there are only two leading noblemen in the lowlands who stay loyal to her. And one of these is Lord Seton, who is the brother of Mary Seton, fashion Mary, the one who's very into her fashion. And the other is a guy called James Hepburn, who is the son of Patrick Hepburn, who we mentioned in the previous episode, the Earl of Bothwell, who was the hereditary Lord Admiral and Sheriff of Edinburgh, who Mary of Guise had been flirting with. And James Hepburn has succeeded to those titles and to the Hermitage, the grim castle in the
要偏远得多）都公开与法国摄政王吉斯的玛丽作对。事实上，低地只有两位主要贵族对她保持忠诚。其中一位是塞顿勋爵，他是玛丽·塞顿（那个非常注重时尚的时尚玛丽）的兄弟；另一位是一个叫詹姆斯·赫本的人，他是我们在上一集提到的帕特里克·赫本的儿子，即博斯韦尔伯爵，他是世袭的海军上将和爱丁堡治安官，吉斯的玛丽曾与他调情。詹姆斯·赫本继承了这些头衔以及赫米蒂奇城堡，那是
debatable lands. And he's a very effective defender of Mary of Guise. And his most spectacular stunt is to pull off an enormous gold heist because Cecil, Elizabeth's minister in England, who's obviously delighted at there being a Protestant revolution in Scotland, he sent a massive train of gold. And James Hepburn, we'll call him Bothwell from now on, Bothwell ambushes it and makes off with all the gold. And the news of this is brought to Mary Stuart in France, Mary, Queen of Scots. And she's terribly touched by this display of loyalty on the part of Bothwell.
争议土地上一座阴森的城堡。他是吉斯的玛丽非常能干的捍卫者。他最壮观的壮举是策划了一场巨大的黄金劫案，因为塞西尔（伊丽莎白在英格兰的大臣，显然对苏格兰爆发新教革命欣喜若狂）运送了一大批黄金，而詹姆斯·赫本（我们从现在开始叫他博斯韦尔）伏击了这批黄金并将其抢走。这个消息传到了身在法国的苏格兰女王玛丽·斯图亚特耳中。她对博斯韦尔这种效忠的表现感动不已。
And from that point on, I think it's fair to say the Earl of Bothwell is a man who will have a place in her heart. She has a certain tondress for Bothwell because she's so grateful to him. And she's completely powerless in all this. I mean, I know she's the queen of France, but she presumably can't do anything to help her mother, Mary of Guise. No, she can't do anything. And she sits there impotently in France watching events in Britain, where it just gets worse and worse from her point of view. So in February 1560, her half-brother Lord James Stuart negotiates a treaty in Berwick, the town on the border of England and Scotland, on behalf of the Lord of the Congregation.
从那一刻起，我认为可以说博斯韦尔伯爵在她心中占据了一席之地。她对博斯韦尔有着某种温情，因为她太感激他了。而且她在这一切中完全无能为力。我的意思是，我知道她是法兰西女王，但她大概无能为力去帮助她的母亲，也就是吉斯的玛丽。不，她什么也做不了。她无能为力地坐在法国，看着英国发生的事情，从她的角度来看，情况变得越来越糟糕。因此，在1560年2月，她同父异母的兄弟詹姆斯·斯图亚特勋爵代表公国贵族议会在英格兰和苏格兰边境小镇贝里克谈判了一项条约。
And this is an overtly Protestant alliance. And the English send a fleet that blockades Mary of Guise in Leith. Elizabeth commits England to protecting Scotland's ancient rights and liberties. So this is not cast as a kind of English invasion and English takeover. But the consequence of this is that the old alliance, the alliance between France and Scotland that had been the foundation stone of Scottish foreign policy for 300 years is now effectively defunct. And whether of a broken heart or not, Mary of Guise gives up the ghost on the 11th of June. She dies only 44. And with her death, everything is kind of thrown up in the air
这是一个公开的新教同盟。英国派遣了一支舰队对利斯实施了封锁，吉斯的玛丽被困其中。伊丽莎白承诺英格兰将保护苏格兰古老的权利和自由。因此，这并没有被塑造成一次英格兰的入侵和接管。但这带来的后果是，老同盟（法国和苏格兰之间作为300年苏格兰外交政策基石的同盟）现在实际上已经不复存在了。无论是否因为心碎，吉斯的玛丽在6月11日撒手人寰。她去世时年仅44岁。随着她的去世，一切都变得
because Scotland now effectively has no ruler, certainly no Catholic ruler. Then one month later, a further calamity for Mary Stuart, who's now lost her mother. A new treaty is signed in Edinburgh between England, the Lords of the Congregation, and in a completely stunning vault façade, her two uncles, the Duke of Guise and the Cardinal of Lorraine, the very people who have been pushing her to take up the rule of England throughout this. And the terms are completely humiliating for Mary Stuart. So France now officially recognizes Elizabeth as Queen of England. They've done it implicitly before. Now it's, you know, it's signed and sealed.
悬而未决，因为苏格兰现在实际上没有统治者，当然也没有天主教统治者。一个月后，对于刚刚失去母亲的玛丽·斯图亚特来说，又是一场灾难。英格兰、公国贵族议会以及（在一个极其惊人的大反转中）她的两个叔叔——吉斯公爵和洛林红衣主教，也就是一路上一直推举她接管英格兰统治的那两个人——在爱丁堡签署了一项新条约。条约条款对玛丽·斯图亚特来说是极其羞辱的。因此，法国现在正式承认伊丽莎白为英格兰女王。他们以前是默认的。现在，这是（你知道的）签字画押了。
Mary is obliged to drop her claim to the throne of England. So again, that is now legal. All French troops are to evacuate Scotland. So those troops that had been sent by Henry the second, that Mary of Guise had been using as her garrisonison as her kind of cutting edge, they all have to withdraw. And it is agreed that any failure on the part of the King of France, Francis and Mary, his queen, to ratify the treaty will license Elizabeth in England to intervene in Scotland to uphold its terms. So it's a complete triumph for the English crown and for the Protestant
玛丽被迫放弃对英格兰王位的继承权。所以同样地，这现在具有了法律效力。所有法国军队必须撤出苏格兰。因此，亨利二世派遣的、吉斯的玛丽一直用作驻军和她某种王牌的那些军队，全部必须撤离。双方商定，如果法兰西国王弗朗西斯和他的王后玛丽未能批准该条约，将授权英格兰的伊丽莎白干预苏格兰以维护条约条款。因此，这对英国王室和苏格兰的
insurgency in Scotland. So I guess Mary has Mary, Queen of Scots at this point has basically only one constellation. So she's lost control of Scotland in so far as she ever had it, which she didn't. She's not going to be Queen of England, but at least she's Queen of France. And she's got this husband who you said he's got two left feet He's too short. He's got a stutter, which you don't rate. He's plucky and smart He's a nice guy and and thank goodness nothing has happened to him and hopefully it won't right Tom, right? So then Mary of geese has died in June and then in mid-november
新教叛乱来说是一场彻底的胜利。所以我想玛丽（苏格兰女王玛丽）此时基本上只有一个安慰。她失去了对苏格兰的控制权（如果她曾经拥有过的话，其实并没有）。她不会成为英格兰女王，但至少她是法兰西女王。她还有这个丈夫——你曾说过他手脚笨拙，个子太矮，还有口吃，你对他评价不高。他勇敢而聪明，是个好人，而且谢天谢地他什么事也没有发生，希望以后也不会，对吧，Tom，对吧？所以随后吉斯的玛丽在6月去世，到了11月中旬，
Francis goes out hunting and he comes back and he says, oh, I'm feeling a bit dizzy and I've got a kind of strange buzzing in my ears. I hope it's nothing serious. By the end of the month, he is suffering a series of violent fits. By early December, weird matter is starting to ooze out of his ears and then it starts coming out as kind of dribble from his mouth. And obviously this isn't a good sign. And on the 5th of December, he dies. Crikey. I mean, you know, you never rated him to be fair.
弗朗西斯出去打猎，回来后他说：“哦，我感觉有点头晕，耳朵里有一种奇怪的嗡嗡声。希望这不是什么严重的病。”到了月底，他开始遭受一系列剧烈的痉挛。到了12月初，奇怪的分泌物开始从他的耳朵里渗出来，然后开始像口水一样从嘴里流出来。显然，这不是什么好兆头。在12月5日，他去世了。天哪。我的意思是，说实话，你从来没看好过他。
I did. I said he was plucky and I said he was smart. That's all you need. But also the other thing you need is not to die of matter coming out of your ears. But he's gone. And for Mary, who it said wept for a month on the news of her mother's death, in a way this is an even more devastating blow because she's still only 17, but she's now been orphaned, she's been widowed, and now she's no longer the Queen
我其实看好过。我说他很勇敢，我也说过他很聪明。这就够了。但除此之外，你还需要做的是不要死于耳朵里流出的分泌物。但他还是走了。对于玛丽来说——据说她听到母亲死讯时哭了整整一个月——在某种程度上，这是一个更具毁灭性的打击，因为她当时年仅17岁，但现在她成了孤儿，成了寡妇，而且现在她不再是
of France. And so her whole future, which had previously seemed so glittering. I mean, now, you know, what's she going to do? Her uncles, these arch manipulators and Machiavelles, they wanted to stay in France because what they want to do is basically to marry her off to Francis' younger brother, Charles, who is now the new king. But Mary is smart enough already to know there is no prospect of this. And the chief problem she faces is her mother-in-law, who Dominic is a link to one of the previous series we did, which is the Medici. So Mary's mother-in-law, so the wife of Henry II, is Catherine de' Medici. So she's from the dukes of Florence. And Catherine de' Medici had always disliked Mary as a kind of tool of the geese. Catherine de' Medici is a very, very smart operator, I mean a ruthless operator and she does not trust Mary. She wants her cleared from the chessboard and she makes
法兰西女王了。因此，她原本看起来如此光明的整个未来。我的意思是，现在，（你知道的）她该怎么办？她的叔叔们，这些超级操纵者和马基雅维利主义者，他们希望她留在法国，因为他们想做的是基本上把她嫁给弗朗西斯的弟弟查尔斯（也就是现在的新王）。但玛丽已经足够聪明，知道这毫无指望。她面临的主要问题是她的婆婆——多米尼克，这与我们制作的之前的一个系列（美第奇家族）有关。所以玛丽的婆婆，也就是亨利二世的妻子，就是凯瑟琳·德·美第奇。所以她来自佛罗伦萨公爵家族。凯瑟琳·德·美第奇一直不喜欢玛丽，认为她是吉斯家族的傀儡。凯瑟琳·德·美第奇是一个非常非常聪明的操盘手，我的意思是，一个冷酷无情的操盘手，她不信任玛丽。她想把玛丽从棋盘上清除出去，并且把这一点
this very clear to Mary. So just one day after Francis's death, she sends a message to Mary saying, Hey, give me back all the jewels. You know, they're not yours anymore. They belong to the queen of France. You're no longer queen of France. Right. She's not messing around. Yeah, she's not.
向玛丽表露得非常清楚。因此，就在弗朗西斯死后仅仅一天，她就给玛丽送去了一条信息，说：“嘿，把所有的珠宝都还给我。你知道的，它们不再属于你了。它们属于法兰西女王。你不再是法兰西女王了。”没错。她可真不是开玩笑的。是的，她绝不是。
And so Mary knows there's no way that Catherine de Medici is going to allow her to marry another of her sons. And the other reason why Mary isn't happy to go along with the schemes of her uncles is that, you know, she views them as having completely stabbed her in the back because they've signed this treaty of Edinburgh. They've deprived her of her right to the throne of England and she feels that they had betrayed both her and her mother. And so because of that, the obvious solution is that she goes back to Scotland because there at least she is Queen of Scots.
因此玛丽知道凯瑟琳·德·美第奇绝不可能允许她嫁给自己的另一个儿子。玛丽不愿意顺从她叔叔们的计划的另一个原因是，（你知道的）她认为他们彻底背叛了她，因为他们签署了《爱丁堡条约》，剥夺了她对英格兰王位的权利，她觉得他们背叛了她和她的母亲。正因如此，显而易见的解决方案就是她返回苏格兰，因为在那里至少她是苏格兰女王。
Do you know what? She should have stayed in France. She should have knuckled down, just kind of had a little palace of her own, had a quiet life, a lot of dancing, and she'd have lived to a ripe old age. This is a great mistake that she makes. Do you know who wouldn't agree with you is Jenny Wormald, the great Scottish historian who also I think was herself Catholic. She feels that Mary should have gone back immediately to Scotland because the sooner she gets back, the better the chance there is of reversing
你知道吗？她本该留在法国的。她本该忍气吞声，建一个自己的小宫殿，过安静的生活，跳跳舞，然后就能安享晚年了。这是她犯下的一个重大错误。你知道谁不会同意你的观点吗？珍妮·沃莫尔德，这位伟大的苏格兰历史学家，我想她自己也是天主教徒。她觉得玛丽应该立即返回苏格兰，因为她越早回去，扭转
the recent successes of Protestantism in Scotland. And the reason for this is that although many of the leading nobility are now Protestant, the vast mass of people in Scotland are still Catholics. They're very like England under Henry VIII. Yeah, of course. And her status as Queen is still unchallenged. As Jenny Wormald puts it, there is no doubt about the strength and prestige of the House of Stuart and the profound unwillingness of the Scots to challenge it. So it's what we were talking about in the first episode. Mary, by virtue of being a Stuart, she can demand a kind of loyalty that is instinctive to the vast number of Scots of her subjects. And so that being so, Wermald argues, I think entirely convincingly, that Mary could have played the part of a Mary Tudor in
苏格兰最近新教胜利的机会就越大。原因在于，尽管许多主要贵族现在都是新教徒，但苏格兰的广大民众仍然是天主教徒。他们非常像亨利八世时期的英格兰。是的，当然。而且她作为女王的地位仍然是无可挑战的。正如珍妮·沃莫尔德所说，斯图亚特家族的力量和声望以及苏格兰人挑战它的强烈不愿，是毫无疑问的。所以这正是我们在第一集里讨论的内容。玛丽凭借自己是斯图亚特家族的人，可以要求一种对她的绝大多数苏格兰臣民来说是本能的忠诚。既然如此，沃莫尔德争辩说（我认为完全令人信服），玛丽本可以在
Scotland. She could have gone back, she could have played the part of a Mary Tudor in Scotland. She could have gone back. She could have sought to reverse the Reformation. And Wermald is very, very down on Mary because of this. I think having myself had two girls who at one point were 17, I think it's quite a big ask to expect a 17-year-old girl who hasn't been to the country that she's being asked to go back to since she was five years old to go back and kind of reverse these seismic developments. I think it's quite tough to be down on Mary for having done the challenge. And I am more sympathetic to Mary for essentially
苏格兰扮演玛丽·都铎的角色。她本可以回去，在苏格兰扮演玛丽·都铎的角色。她本可以回去。她本可以设法扭转宗教改革。因此沃莫尔德对玛丽非常严厉。我想，我自己有两个曾一度17岁的女儿，我认为要求一个17岁的女孩——自从五岁起就没去过她被要求回去的那个国家——回去扭转这些翻天覆地的变化，要求确实太高了。我认为因为玛丽迎接了这项挑战而对她过于苛刻是不对的。对于玛丽本质上的
prevaricating. So rather than hurrying back to Scotland, she goes into mourning for Francis, so that lasts 40 days. She then goes on a kind of massive tour around France saying goodbye to all her relatives and her pals and so on. And she is also, throughout this, engaging in kind of massive slanging matches with Nicholas Throgmorton, the English ambassador, who is trying to pressure her to sign the Treaty of Edinburgh, which he refuses point blank to do. However, she is preparing to go back to Scotland. And the key figure in her plans is her half brother, Lord James Stuart. And the reason for that is that I think Mary
拖延，我报以更多的同情。因此，与其急着赶回苏格兰，她先为弗朗西斯服丧，持续了40天。然后她开始在法国进行一次大规模的巡游，与所有的亲戚和朋友告别等等。而且在此期间，她还与英格兰大使尼古拉斯·思罗克莫顿进行了大规模的激烈争吵，后者试图施压让她签署她断然拒绝签署的《爱丁堡条约》。不过，她确实在准备返回苏格兰。她计划中的关键人物是她同父异母的兄弟，詹姆斯·斯图亚特勋爵。原因在于，我认为玛丽
instinctively when in trouble looks to her family, even though her mother had not let her down, but her uncles have done. So there is a problem with Lord James Stewart, which is of course that he's a Protestant and not just a Protestant, but he's basically been the kind of the leader of the Lords of the Congregation. But as I say, he is family and Mary is obviously hoping that blood is thicker than water. And sure enough, between them, they arrive at a kind of an agreement, a compact, that when it's announced, appalls both her geez uncles and John Knox. And the reason for that, the reason that the compact appalls the geez is that Mary promises to recognize the reformed churchalls the Gies is that Mary promises to recognise
在遇到麻烦时，本能地会把希望寄托在家人身上，尽管她的母亲没有让她失望，但她的叔叔们确实让她失望了。所以詹姆斯·斯图亚特勋爵有一个问题，当然就是他是个新教徒，不仅是个新教徒，而且基本上一直是公国贵族议会的领袖。但正如我所说，他是家人，玛丽显然希望血浓于水。果不其然，他们之间达成了一种协议、一种契约。当这个消息宣布时，她的吉斯叔叔们和约翰·诺克斯都大惊失色。之所以这样，之所以这个契约让吉斯家族大惊失色，是因为玛丽承诺承认
the Reformed Church, the Protestant Church that John Knox is kind of now the leading light of as being Scotland's official church. In return, she will be allowed to celebrate the Catholic mass in her own chapel at Holyrood, which is the Royal Palace in Edinburgh. And I think there's no real question as to who gets the better of that deal. I mean, clearly, Mary is selling Catholic Scotland down the river, really. Right. But at least she'll be able to go back as Queen, right? So, you know, it's a big win for her. And as a Catholic Queen. And so she leaves Calais on the 14th of August 1561 and with her go her four beloved Mary's and they stand on the deck saying adieu, adieu, bidding tearful farewells to France, mourning the fact that they worry they will never see France again, which is entirely accurate.
归正教会（也就是约翰·诺克斯现在成为领军人物的新教教会）为苏格兰的官方教会。作为交换，她将被允许在荷里路德（爱丁堡的王宫）她自己的小教堂里举行天主教弥撒。我认为毫无疑问是谁在这笔交易中占了上风。显然，玛丽实际上是把天主教苏格兰给出卖了。没错。但至少她可以作为女王回去了，对吧？所以，你知道的，这对她来说是一场大胜利。而且是以天主教女王的身份。因此，她于1561年8月14日离开加来，同她一起走的还有她深爱的四位玛丽，她们站在甲板上道别，向法国做最后泪眼婆娑的告别，哀叹她们担心再也见不到法国了，而这完全是准确的。
Mary will never see France again, which is entirely accurate. Mary will never see France again. They're a bit worried because Mary still hasn't signed the Treaty of Edinburgh with Elizabeth. And so they're worried that the English may be looking out for her to try and take a hostage. And in fact, as they are going up the Northumbrian coast, one of her transport ships, which is carrying her horses, gets picked up by an English patrol ship on suspicion of piracy and taken into Newcastle. So these horses are impounded and it will take three months for them finally to be sent north to Edinburgh. Mary herself, she gets to Scotland to Leith in record time, only takes her five days, no seasickness of course because she's so poised, and they arrive off Leith and the harbour is thickly
玛丽再也见不到法国了，这完全是准确的。玛丽再也见不到法国了。她们有点担心，因为玛丽还没有同伊丽莎白签署《爱丁堡条约》。因此她们担心英国人可能会盯着她，试图抓一个人质。事实上，当她们沿着诺森伯兰海岸航行时，她的一艘运送马匹的运输船被一艘英国巡逻船以涉嫌海盗罪截获，并被带到了纽卡斯尔。所以这些马匹被扣押了，花了三个月的时间才最终被送到北方的爱丁堡。玛丽本人以创纪录的时间到达了苏格兰的利斯，只用了五天，当然由于她姿态优雅并没有晕船。她们到达利斯港外时，港口被浓密的
veiled by mist so that Mary in a kind of, it's pregnant with symbolism, can't actually make out the contours of her kingdom through this sea mist. And John Knox, I mean, he's a man ready to see it as an omen. And he wrote, the very face of heaven at the time of her arrival did manifestly speak what comfort was brought unto this country with her, to wit sorrow, dolor, darkness, and impiety. But Dominic, was he right? Well we love a bit of darkness and impiety on the rest is history and I'm happy to say that next time there'll be loads of both as we explore the melodramatic story of Mary Queen of Scots on her return to Scotland. Now if you cannot wait to hear that story,
大雾笼罩，以至于玛丽——在某种充满象征意义的情境中——实际上无法透过这层海雾看清她王国的轮廓。而约翰·诺克斯，我的意思是，他是一个随时准备将此视为不祥之兆的人。他写道：“当她到达时，天堂的面貌清楚地说明了给这个国家带来的究竟是什么安慰，即悲伤、痛苦、黑暗和不虔诚。”但是，多米尼克，他说得对吗？好吧，我们在《历史余音》中就是喜欢黑暗和不虔诚，我很高兴地说，下一次我们将探索苏格兰女王玛丽返回苏格兰的苦情故事时，会有大量这两者的内容。现在，如果你等不及要听那个故事——
which is one of the most remarkable we've ever done, the great news is that you can hear it and the remaining three episodes of this series by joining our very own group of Evangelical Reformers, the Lords of the Congregation, the Rest is History Club at therestishistory.com. So what are you waiting for? And on that bombshell, goodbye. Bye bye. It's David Oleshoge from Journey Through Time. Here's that clip that we mentioned earlier.
这是我们做过的最非凡的故事之一——好消息是，你可以通过加入我们自己的福音派改革者群体（公国贵族议会，即“历史余音俱乐部”，网址为 therestishistory.com）来收听这个故事以及本系列的其余三集。还在等什么？伴随着这个重磅消息，再见。再见。我是来自《穿越时空》的大卫·奥莱肖吉。以下是我们之前提到的那段剪辑。
If you look at all of the accounts of the fire at this point, as we get to the end of Sunday the 2nd, the first day, this fire is not behaving in any way the way fires traditionally did in London. And there is some people who've argued that it was becoming a firestorm, that the heat and the wind and the movement of air caused by the fire was feeding, it was becoming self-sustaining as it were. John Evelyn, who's a great writer and a diarist of this moment, he talks about the sound of the fire. He said it was like
如果你看看所有关于这场火灾的记载，当我们走到周日（即第二天）结束时，这场火灾的行为方式与伦敦历史上传统的火灾完全不同。有些人认为它正在变成一场火风暴，火灾产生的热量、风力和空气流动正在为其提供给养，可以说它正在变得能够自我维持。约翰·伊夫林（John Evelyn）是当时的一位伟大作家和日记作家，他谈到了火灾的声音。他说那听起来像
thousands of chariots driving over cobblestones. There are descriptions in Peeps and elsewhere of this great arc of fire in the sky. I mean, imagine that everything around you is coloured by the flames, yellows and oranges, and above you is this thick black smoke. This is a city you know, these are streets you walk, this is a place that's deeply familiar to you, and it looks completely otherworldly. It looks like another, like a sort of landscape you've never seen before. This is a place that's deeply familiar to you, and it looks completely otherworldly. It looks like another, like a sort of landscape you've never seen before.
成千上万辆战车驶过鹅卵石路面的声音。佩皮斯和其他人的日记中都描述了天空中这个巨大的火弧。我是说，想象一下你周围的一切都被火焰染成了黄色和橙色，头顶则是浓密的黑烟。这是一座你熟悉的城市，这是你走过的街道，这是一个你深感熟悉的地方，但它看起来却完全像另一个世界。它看起来就像是你从未见过的一种风景。这是一个你深感熟悉的地方，但它看起来却完全像另一个世界。它看起来就像是你从未见过的一种风景。
People describe the Fire almost as if it's supernatural. If you wanna hear the full episode, listen to Journey Through Time, wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
人们对这场大火的描述简直就像它是超自然的一样。如果你想收听完整节目，请在各大播客平台搜索并收听《穿越时空》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。